so I've got a question have you heard of
the boy and the Heron you know hayo
Miyazaki the studio ghibli's last movie
no well that's on purpose it looks like
the movie titled how do you live in
Japan is finally set with a December
release for the rest of the world and
throughout its entire run in Japan
earlier this year there was a very
purposeful heir of mystery around it
they did basically zero advertising for
it in an effort to Veil it in a sense of
Mystique from the looks of it and now
that we finally have a date and preview
I think talk of this is going to spread
like wildfire Ghibli movies are held in
remarkably high regard in the west even
among non-anime fans so the second the
folks begin to see previews of
miyazaki's final film especially with
how gorgeous it looks these showings are
going to sell like crazy I can't wait
and well let's also see if this is
really his final film